Hi there, yeah, the STDConnix just down there. This is that you're cleaning. Oh, you're
here to clean your ears. I apologize, guess. Hello, please come, sit down, sit down. Um,
I will just ask you a few questions and then we'll get started right away. I believe you
are my half-eleven appointment. Good. And yeah, I've just got a general ear cleaning
here. Do you have repeated experience with this? Mm, okay. Alright, I will get my gloves
on, do an inspection, and we will take it from there, okay? Mm, no, no, it's a quiet day today.
So, I will have fun looking after you. I just want to assure you, nothing to be worried about,
not gonna do anything without your say so, and obviously, because ears are very sensitive,
and if you need me to stop at any time, I absolutely will, okay? Um, so I'll just take a quick,
yes, they are very condensed, they are very blocked, which, I think you're actually gonna
present me with a challenge for once. I don't normally have, well, the normal procedure is just
hot water into the ear canal, but I have a sneaking suspicion that you are really gonna be testing
me. I'm just gonna spray this solution, okay? Just saline solution, it's salty, and in theory,
it should help break down the fats that are trapped in your ear. How does that feel?
Just gonna get a wipe, that's pain to me. Okay, let's try the bottle. Is that sore? No, not sore,
okay, I'm just gonna see if this brush is gonna make a difference. Well, I think I should
congratulate you for having the most stubborn earwax I think I've ever seen before. Anything?
Well, I don't think the brush is gonna cut it, so what I'm gonna do is get my tweezers. I'm gonna
try and do this very gently, because I know you said that it doesn't hurt, which is good,
which is very good. I do not want it to start hurting, so just... I think I just fixed the
problem. Now, when I ask you this, I request for you to be as honest as possible. Did you use ear
cleaners in your ear, and then the cotton became dislodged in your ear? Because I just pulled out
a massive wad of cotton. You know how on the boxes there's a big warning that says, do not put in
your ears. Yeah, this is the exact scenario why, so I assume that's exactly what's wrong on this side as well.
Tell you what, I'm gonna try and fix this ear first, because that definitely did not get all...
No, back to your other ear.
I'm definitely clear to you. I can't see any deeper, you know, conqueror that should affect your hearing.
Which I would like to hear. I'm just going to give you a few more sprays of that solution, because as much
as ears are self-cleaning, some ears are not as good at self-cleaning as they should be, so a little bit
cold. Okay.
Rub it in. Okay, a little bit of wax filled up, but just, you know, next time you're in the shower,
you're in the bath, just take a bottle of soap and rub it on your hands, and then do it on the top of the ear,
all on the outside of the ear, not the canal, the outside of the ear. Do not put anything inside the canal,
and that goes for Q-tips, or ear cleaners, or whatever have you. I've just got this little pump device to dry the earwax,
because I will be able to pick out the earwax now that it's dried up. It's just your basic extraction, so nothing to worry about.
I promise you, and I've lost my tool. Of course, I lost my tools, right behind me.
Right, this is just a soft, feel that soft wooden, okay. I'm just going to use it to carve out the wax that's piled up.
Unfortunately, for future treatments, the best I can recommend is a hot shower, or hot bath, to let your ears steam,
and then get in a basic tissue, and don't place it deep into the ear canal, just against the ear canal,
and no more to pick up any wax that may be sitting on your ears, okay? That's good.
I believe you. I will know to your other ear to remember if I hadn't lost my tool again.
Same thing as before, I'm just going to go in nice and gently.
There we go. That was so bad. It's a delicate job, it really is. I'm just going to move my chair closer to you.
Alright, that's a lot easier for me to be all up in your wrist, isn't it?
Just a very quick check that I've got everything. What's my trusty tweezers?
Yeah, that's good. I'll do the same thing again, where I'll spray some cold spritz.
There we go. Just massage it in a little. Do you still have that pain or discomfort, or is it gone now?
Okay, that's very good news. I'll just dry you off again.
It's so cold. Don't think it would be very appropriate if I were to do well all over again,
so I'll apologize for the cold. To maybe right back to picking out the wax. Just hold still for me.
Let us rest my hand on your face a little, just steady on the both of us.
Oh, that's good.
There we go.
Just going to wait for the excess on the back of my glove, don't worry.
This is why we glove up, but you already know that it protects the patient as much as it protects the practitioner.
Does that feel a little better?
I'll just warn you that if this incident were to occur again, please do just come straight into the clinic because blockages can actually lead to incredibly nasty infections.
And that's the last thing anyone wants to deal with right now.
Okay, so that's what I can do there. Just checking. This is just a soft brush.
I'll take another look just to make sure that I've done my eye tone, because I don't want to send you away to everyone.
If you do end up having pain, obviously you just come straight back to the clinic. Just hold your head up, look straight ahead.
Yeah, that is a little bit more deal for me to clean them up a bit better.
Honestly, as long as the blockage is removed, that is more certainly the main thing. I think we can both agree.
Just taking a look at my toenails to see if I have anything else that may be a pain with them.
Now this brush does go deeper into the canal. Do not be startled. It won't hurt.
But again, if you have any discomfort, please just tell me. Look straight ahead again for me.
There's that. Yeah, that may even be ticklish. But don't worry, because we dried the wax, it is very easy to also get any dust out.
Let's just check on the outside of the foil a little bit.
A little bit more.
That's okay.
I wish I had steadier hands for this job, but me too.
As long as I don't poke anyone's ear drum out, I probably shouldn't say that.
I wouldn't say that, although I have a tool inside your ear.
A little bit on the outside.
Okay.
I'm quite happy with that. If you're happy with it, I am happy with it. I can do a very basic hearing test on you.
It is not with equipment, that is my only note. It's what we actually do when we have younger patients with us.
It is your very basic left or right ear. You can just raise your hand or look in the direction that you hear the noise.
Very simplistic in nature. Just to make sure that your hearing is back to one on one.
The deeper noises, no one really struggles with them, it's the later.
Yeah, the older you get, the frequencies that you can hear get less and less.
Well, the higher pitch they are, which is why we have quite an array of things to test and obviously when it's a child, you have to try and entertain them as much as possible.
Or when the restless is incredibly hard to treat, a restless patient, but it's understandable. You're tired, you don't feel good.
This one actually, if you don't mind me reaching behind you, I do apologize.
It's very unprofessional. This one is probably one of the most rated for nasis.
Yes, I'm not sure how many. Honestly, so if a patient is presenting with limited,
capacity for hearing, we can ignore my dull right away, such as having to use louder voice, but it's quite nice to speak the lower tone.
As you can imagine with the older patients as well, you very much have to enunciate every word.
But yeah, your left and right ear is perfectly fine. If I look inside the ear, I can't see anything unless it's very, very deep inside your ear and you have a hidden crevice, you have a hidden area that I can't see.
This is the last test. I'm not worried about you at all.
I believe that's all I can do for you, although I tell a lie, I can send you away with the same liquid formula.
If you feel your ears are starting to be congested again or blocked off or feel you can't hear, try this solution.
I want you to use it in your ear and then lie down so the liquid stays in the canal for as long as possible and then get tissue to remove anything that leaks out once you sit up right again.
Is there anything else I can do for you?
Nope. Alright, then you take this home with you and I can give you some approved medical ear cleaning tools. Do not shove them in your canals or I will come after you.
If you take these with you, thank you very much and as cruel as this sounds, hopefully our paths don't meet again because it means your ear health is fantastic.
Thank you so much. Bye now.